تم إخلائي من معسكر قاعدة
إيفرست بعد ظهور أعراض فيروس كوفيد 19 على
ارتفاع 5000 متر ،
شعرت بالضعف ولم أعاني من صداع
وكان مستوى بشرتي منخفضًا جدًا
في معسكر الرذيلة.
كان متسلق الجبال النرويجي في رئتي إرلين نيس
ميديفاك إلى المستشفى
في عاصمة نيبال كاتماندو ، فقد
وضع نهاية مؤقتة لحلمه الذي دام عقدًا من الزمن
في تسلق جبل
إيفرست عندما أثبتت إصابتي في كوريا
، كانت صدمة
، ثم أدركت أن الرحلة الاستكشافية
قد انتهت
بالنسبة لي في  التحضير للحدث الذي
تدربت فيه nesa لمدة ساعتين يوميًا لمدة ستة
أشهر وقد تسلقت بالفعل ستة من
أعلى سبع قمم في
العالم وحاولت مرة واحدة في أي وقت مضى في
عام 2018. إن
قمة أكبر جبل في
العالم هو حلم كبير
لكل متسلق على ما أعتقد  كنت أرغب في الوقوف
على القمة ورؤية المنظر بعد دخول
نيس المستشفى في كاتماندو
، يقول إنه أثبت إصابته بكوفيتز
ثلاث مرات
وهو يتعافى الآن
، ويقول إنه حصل على  اختبار مبدئي قبل
التوجه إلى الجبل ولا يعرف من
أين التقط الفيروس ، قال
مصدران من معسكر القاعدة لشبكة CNN أنه
كان هناك
العشرات من حالات كوفيد 19 المشتبه بها هناك
في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ،
لكن المتحدث باسم إدارة السياحة في نيبال
نفى ذلك  كانت
هناك أي حالات ، حيث يأتي هذا في الوقت
الذي تكافح فيه الهند المجاورة
أسوأ انتشار لكوفيد 19 في
العالم ، ولا تزال الحدود بين البلدين مفتوحة.
بطريقة
ما حتى توفي شخص ما في المستشفى عندما
مكثت هناك ، لذلك
كان من الممكن أن يزداد الأمر سوءًا ،
ومن المرجح أن يؤدي هذا التهديد المتطور بسرعة في نيبال إلى
عرقلة إعادة الافتتاح التدريجي لـ Everest
حيث تم منح أكثر من 400 متسلق
تصاريح هذا الربيع ،
وهو الموسم الرئيسي لمحاولة تسلق
العالم.  أعلى ذروة
كريستي لوستوت CNN